welcome welcome thank you so much for
coming it's great to have all of you
here today on this beautiful day I mean
beautiful days we've had in New Haven
weather-wise for a long time and here
you are indoors
thanks to your dedication to the work
that you're going to talk about today
and hear others describe I'm Steve petty
I'm faculty and American Studies in erm
in history and the director of the RIT M
Center and we've been looking forward to
this event for a long time we were
looking for an opportunity to see you
all in action to see people present
about their work and yet just as
importantly maybe more importantly give
people the opportunity to hear from one
another because I think one of the
things that this place doesn't do as
well as it might is give folks the
opportunity to engage with one another
about their work in progress about their
research in progress too often all of us
are sort of dug into our own projects
stuck in our own holes digging digging
digging and we may not know who's
digging what just a few feet away from
us so here we have that opportunity
right to learn from one another to think
collaboratively to think across
disciplines all more or less around
topics related to questions surrounding
race and diginity transnational
migration and similar things so last
year here in the RIT M Center we had the
opportunity the extraordinary
opportunity to support research work by
undergraduates graduate students and
professional students around campus a
total of 52 students from all categories
received some form of support from us
and we're really really fortunate and
proud that we were able to support
students from so many different parts of
the university from 17 different
departments programs and divisions of
the university both in this part of
campus central campus the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences yield college the OU
graduate school but also extending out
to the medical school the nursing school
the art school architecture divinity
forestry and environmental studies and
so forth so this is what our part of our
mandate is here in RIT M is to try to
nurture and enable that work in all
parts where we can help and then to
bring that work together in one place as
best we can to make sure that you all
can hear from one another so we're
excited about the opportunity to
to bring that work together to give you
the chance to present and to hear from
one another about the work that you've
done and to make this space available to
to enable collaboration and elaboration
in the hour or so to come so what we
have today is a subset a fraction of the
work that happened over the summer I
think 12 presentations and we thank all
of you for being here today for for
answering the call and as summer
awardees to come and share your work
with it and one another thanks so much
well we're gonna ask everybody to do is
to speak for no more than three minutes
about their work we have put together a
program and the PowerPoint presentations
are already in order so they will load
automatically and that should make this
easier for everybody as you can see I'm
holding a microphone we ask you to also
hold the microphone so we can catch this
on tape and make sure that this is
recorded well we'll let you know when
you have a minute left and then when
your time is up so we hope that you'll
you know enjoy this settle in have fun
with this but also stick to time
hi my name is amber Dromgoole I'm in the
department's of religious studies and
african-american studies
oh there we go
okay this summer while presenting my
research on 20th century gospel composer
Roxy Ann Moore at the biannual Christian
congregational Music Conference in
Oxford England I had the opportunity to
converse and fellowship with a group of
scholars researching black sacred music
traditions spanning the Atlantic these
discussions opened the door for
sustained global conversation and
collaboration concerning the nature of
black sound consciousness and self
making from United States 20th century
great migration narratives and the
lasting impact of black southern
migrants to northern cities on black
expressive culture to the onset and
effect of the mid 20th century Windrush
movement of Caribbean West African
populations creating a multi-faceted
black British community negotiating
collective significance against nuanced
cultural offerings and traditions the
dialogue was incredibly dynamic this to
say in addition to my own research
concerning the creation evolution and
innovation of black musical production
and sound as analyzed and described
through the life of Roxy and more I was
able to add this transatlantic component
to which she was also a contributor and
beneficiary to my research which was a
direct result of my travels and rhythms
support while my initial work this
summer was supposed to follow the trails
of Roxy and Moore and legendary
twentieth-century vocal group the Golden
Gate quartet I found my work taking
different turns as a result of robust
conversation held with my black British
colleagues for example letters I found
in Rock sirs archive prior to my travels
informed me of how the gates first
arrived in Paris in the mid-1950s
to explore new economic opportunities
after their light began to dim the
United States and music labels started
casting them aside for seemingly
brighter stars
I knew the black Americans in the mid
20th century viewed Paris as a place of
freedom and liberation from the economic
and racial turmoil of the United States
and that the ambassadorship of jazz
artists opened a window for other black
musical artists and groups like the
Golden Gate quartet to find audiences in
Europe but through this summer's
research I learned that Windrush the
mass migration of West Indian and West
African migrants to Europe from the mid
to late 20th century coincided with
these efforts adding several other
dimensions to an ever-evolving black
Europe
soundscape during the Christian
congregational music conference
I learned to chinnabbai gaudium folk
songs that migrants brought with them
songs combined with the sounds of a
burgeoning gospel music industry
scholars observed how the
commercialization and commodification of
black American sacred music practices
affected Caribbean and West African
artistic retentions as they sought to
adapt to new landscapes while keeping
home near discussions surrounded the
Americanization of dialect and
pronunciation when recording music came
up time and time again this experience
has shifted my research in a new and
dynamic directions and I'm grateful to
rhythm for allowing me the opportunity
to open such a necessary dialogue thank
you
[Applause]
hi I'm Michelle Johnson I am a second
year in history and African American
Studies so my research looked at the
civil rights movement generally it looks
at civil rights movements and places
outside of the south so I start with a
great migration starting around 1916
when black folks were moving from the
south up to northern industrial cities
and from there I look at how those same
black folks in cities took their
southern roots to coast happening in the
south and made the civil rights movement
their own so as black southerners moved
into Chicago specifically they said
about rebuilding and creating new
institutions these included churches and
schools as well as branches of
organizations like the n-double-a-cp
and Congress of racial equality early on
in the civil rights era many of these
groups were strategically made
interracial which is how I found myself
kind of unexpectedly looking at the
papers of faith rich white women who
worked as an unpaid staffer for the
Chicago n-double-a-cp beginning in 1945
and working all the way until she passed
away in the 1990s in her more than 50
years living in a black neighborhood on
the west side of Chicago she involved
herself in nearly every education
related battle for equality as well as
political struggle struggles over urban
renewal policies though much of her work
was created was working on creating
research for reports she was also not
afraid of Jordan or organizing doing a
lot of black work or a block-based
organizing work Chicago civil rights
movements were in some ways very similar
to movements in the south much of the
organizing started with desegregating
restaurants and roller rinks but then
went on to schools and eventually
housing and then eventually a lot of
black power ish movements working on
black business these individual
movements sort of broken down
issue-by-issue
we're also happening all at once
throughout time and ended up being
continued over the period starting
around 1916 to 1970 so while you can
break them down issue-by-issue they also
were concurrent throughout and one of
the most dramatic moments in 1963 200
and thousand public school students
stayed home from school to protest
inequality in public education three
years later before the schools came to a
resolution my luther king moved into the
city to fight for open housing local
people on the ground juggled these
shifting priorities as focus changed
over time
the majority of my sources up to this
point doing research for a couple years
we're not personal in nature so I looked
a lot of reports created by community
organizations internal memos drafted
drafts of speeches things like that but
this was one of the first archives that
I came across that had letters back and
forth to husband and wife for example
and I had to figure out what to make of
that it's a different type of source I
never had come across it what do you do
and I found that actually it was really
helpful in piecing together what the
role of a white woman in a black
activist position meant and how she felt
about it and how she took it on and how
her neighbors felt about it and how her
family felt about it
so it really shifted my focus on my
research and to not only black folks
organizing about issues that affected
them but also the ways that coalition
was working in the city of Chicago in
this period thank you
[Applause]
hi my name is Heidi I'm a senior history
major here at Yale the summer I was
fortunate to receive funding from the
RIT M Center to visit a series of
archives in the Midwest but in
particular I was investigating the
relationship between the entangled
relationship between railroad expansion
and the white earth and red Lake
reservations in northwestern Minnesota
in the late 19th and early 20th
centuries what I found increasingly in
my research by looking at Indian agent
correspondence and Diaries and maps and
transcribed oral histories was how much
railroads really affected both
reservation policies and euro American
settlers access to these lands so in
1889 the Nelson Act was established in
Minnesota that basically granted
settlers euro American settlers access
and settlement upon both the white earth
and red lake reservations and also
allowed timber tycoons to access these
reservations so I started looking at
maps for example from 1887 that showed a
Transcontinental Railroad passing just
south of the reservation and all the
lands and orange represent lands that
were available for sale this reveals the
degree of pressure that railroads
applied on these reservations and
therefore allowed for settlement on the
reservations likewise only 15 years
later we see the effect of regional
railroads and the presence of railroads
on the reservations so that this
railroad the Soo line passed right
through the heart of white earth and
just skirted Red Lake that allowed
timber tycoons and land speculators to
gain access to the land which in turn
allowed for the de neuting of the
landscape and white settlers to
basically take over these reservations
the effects of these are relative
railroad expansion was just devastating
for the native populations here we see a
Jib way of women practicing her
traditional maple sugaring and likewise
other practices such as while the ricing
became very endangered because of the
intensive logging practices that were
occurring because of the railroad
expansion and so we see basically that
how how greatly railroads are implicated
in this process of environmental
degradation land dispossession and the
cultural practices that suffered
thereafter
and so it was a super fortunate to
engage with a series of photographs such
as the one with Roland Reed here and all
these different maps and Indonesian
correspondence that just shed light on
this story that's otherwise been
somewhat neglected in the history and
historiography of the period most people
have focused on just the policies
themselves instead of the vehicles that
allowed these policies to be enacted so
thank you
[Applause]
hi my name is Jacqueline Lee I'm a third
year history PhD students any Latin
American history and this summer I went
to London for my research thanks to
money from RIT M so my research is on
the bay of Honduras in the mosquito
shore in the 18th century
so the bay of Honduras occupied the
region that is today Belize you'll see
it in yellow on the map labeled British
Honduras and the mosquito shore occupied
the Caribbean coast of modern-day
southern Honduras in Nicaragua so it
comes down the pink and green here on
the right side of the screen so the
significance of the time and place come
into play in the context of early modern
Atlantic empires here specifically we're
dealing with Britain and Spain and Spain
by right of discovery and the authority
of the papal bull of 1493 claimed
absolute sovereignty over the entire
expanse of the Americas west of the line
drawn in the Treaty of Tordesillas
so of course this is how it worked in
theory but in reality Spain didn't have
the manpower and the Spanish authorities
on the ground didn't have the
inclination to completely explore and
take a hold of the territory in all of
Spanish America and especially on this
Caribbean coast of New Spain the terrain
was jungle filled and the coast
languished treacherous and so Europeans
really made few entries into this region
the British eventually came to get a
foothold here in the bay in particular
in the yellow area and as the
historiographical
the Golden Age of buccaneering as it
comes to an end the Buccaneers who would
have been among the best sailors of this
region would have been able to navigate
the treacherous Keys and reefs coming
into the bay so you can see the map of
the water as it moves around these
islands it would have been really hard
to actually access the land mass of this
coast of Central America
so as Jamaica changes hands from Spain
to Britain in the late 17th century and
sugar planters are beginning to
establish their lucrative businesses
here the European powers agreed that
buccaneering needed to come to an end in
this new age of order in the Caribbean
so as a result the Buccaneers who had
been operating in the Caribbean sought
new sources of income and they turned to
enterprise as they had already been
starting which were cutting log wood and
mahogany from this region so as these
trades expand
Spain and Britain begin to vie for
sovereignty of the region and the
traditional story that's told of this is
about an Anglo Spanish conflict so my
question in researching this has been
challenging the historiography to look
at other sides that are not simply about
European sovereignty and specifically
about the Mosquito Indians who actually
held territorial political and political
control of this region and a geographer
Karl often writes that this region was
only called mosquito or the mosquito
Shore because of the mosquitoes spatial
practices otherwise it would have only
been some other place in Central America
so my research looks at how the Mosquito
Indians were not only crucial in
facilitating European forays into the
region but also I'd like to take
seriously the words themselves so for
example why has sovereignty not been
used in the historiography of this
region and how can we apply that taking
into account contemporary challenges
that the mosquito people still face
within your corral and government and
questioning the ethics and how far we
can actually push the history and
questions in this region so that's my
word thank you
[Applause]
hello my name is Eva Rosario I'm a third
year in American Studies and women
gender and sexuality studies and this
summer I had the opportunity to do
archival research which is something
that I've never done before so I want to
thank stiff or gently pushing me in the
last two years to go beyond my methods
and improve them so I guess at one of
the gains was like to not be scared
anymore of the archive and I think
that's like a big big step so I had the
opportunity together make friends with
the archival people and get to know
materials how to do research how is the
archive organized so I kind of learned
that and my question was well what is
the global circulation of contemporary
art on the war on drugs and white level
circulation because I wanted to see how
there were different interpretations of
the mexican war on drugs which is my
main area of research in aesthetics as
how we are feeling this violence from a
global perspective so I went to four
archives the first one was in WAC which
is a Muslim University Delta
contemporanea which is a University
Museum of unum which is the main public
national university in Mexico and there
what I found was fascinating because I
found embroiderers which were women that
intro that embroidered the name of
victims of the war on drugs of
casualties so it was very interesting to
see how I forgot forgotten about that
like I had forgotten about all those
visual artistic manifestations that have
been taking place in the last ten years
so that was like in a way this research
was also like self autographic because I
found like a lot of stuff that I had
forgotten like what was forgetting was
for sure like one of the most important
elements of this historical record then
I went to Paris to the st. Pompidou I
found nothing so like but that absence
is important because it really speaks of
the circulation of argan like the
geographical distribution of certain
topics or concerns then I went to castle
in Germany where Documenta one of the
most important contemporary art first
takes place every five years and then
what I found were like more since I'm
not looking for history or like
Taylor historiography I am mostly
looking for metaphors or like I don't
like the word sign but like symbols that
let me think beyond what I what I'm
already thinking so I found a lot of
metaphors there and finally I was in
Benny's in where W&L at the Venice
Biennale which is like the oldest
Contemporary Art Fair takes place and
this is the work of terrorism are
gorgeous one of the most relevant
contemporary Mexican artists and the
name of this art piece is the search and
it's relevant because it shows like
posters of the government as looking or
searching for women that are missing and
what it's like so sadly and painful is
that these are like from 2009-2011 so
when we see the massive demonstration
demonstrations of women in the like in
our hemisphere we can see like how all
that phenomenon is so that's what I
found
[Applause]
hello my name is aekta padartha and i'm
a third year PhD student in american
studies today our public schools in the
US are asked segregated as they were
when the Supreme Court ruled in Brown
versus Board of Education
what's more states like New York and
California are among the most segregated
of those states but how did we get here
well by the 1980's constitutionally
mandated integration of schools had been
largely undermined through legislation
like California's Prop 21 which
prohibited mandatory busing today
schools continue to contend with the
effects of white flight redistricting
and the rise in private and charter
school enrollment yet state-funded
school programs working to improve
graduation rates and increase access to
higher education largely ignore the
realities of inequity produced through
school segregation one such program is
avid which stands for advancement via
individual determination in 1980 a high
school English teacher named Mary
Katherine Swanson founded the avid
program at a public high school in San
Diego County as schools restructured to
accommodate for changes in student
demographics and budget capacity caused
by factors like refugee refugee
resettlement and the privatization of
education avid was advertised as a
remedy an educational innovation to
close the achievement gap today avid is
offer today avid is offered in 47 states
and 16 countries worldwide in popular
coverage Swanson is celebrated as a
visionary educator with a plan and the
gods who disseminate it yet these very
accounts celebrate her individual grit
and tenacity without emphasizing the
collective of mentors educators and
administrators that make avid as
successful as it is even the name
advancement via individual determination
pushes forward a neoliberal vision of
public education it is up to the
individual student determination if they
go to college so my research asks how is
the resegregate of schools and the
unequal distribution of resources
rendered invisible behind programs like
avid
furthermore how is the avid pedagogy
implemented in other education programs
designed for indigenous and migrant
communities within the San Diego region
with the support of riddim I conducted
archival and ethnographic research this
summer to examine how different
educational institutions in San Diego
addressed the achievement gap in schools
primarily I worked at the VA hostage
ocation Center or V Tech located on the
viejos to me a reservation in East
County San Diego V Tech provides
after-school tutoring college readiness
and life management skills workshops for
students who are children of enrolled
tribal members in an oral history I
conducted with Teressa of the high
school student coordinator at V Tech she
stated the greatest need within the
public school district is tutoring
services for all students not just those
in avid or those at part of V Tech
looking forward I will analyze how
collaborative mentorship functions
differently across avid VTech and Yala
which is a nonprofit that uses a
combination of after-school tutoring and
team soccer to prepare migrant students
to enter college as San Diego County
continues to lead in refugee
resettlement
I hope my research will support and
promote pedagogy zuv and for liberation
thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Tiana Reid
I am a joint PhD student in history in
African American Studies if I asked
everyone to take out some money right
now you might pull out a dollar bill a
coin or even a debit or credit card it
wouldn't be difficult for many of us in
the room right now but there was a time
in the early modern period where money
was not standard and if I acts the same
question in the 17th or 18th century you
might pull out a Spanish piece of eight
a French livre English or Dutch Bills of
exchange and you could all be in the
same British colony for my research I am
exploring I am connecting this early
modern history of the complicated
monetary supply with the rented out
labor and Sunday markets of Africans and
their descendants particularly I am
exploring the economic activities of
freedom enslaved people of color in
Barbados Jamaica in South Carolina from
1650 to 1770
I am tracing their sources of income the
economies they participated in and how
their lives too were affected by the
early modern monetary supply wondering
how they paid for their manumission
wondering how they paid for rent for
clothes for food through my analysis of
the money of freed and enslaved people
of color I hope to provide an early
modern basis for thinking about economic
inequality not only in terms of the
difference for how much money people
have but also in the difference in the
types of money that people have access
to and finally I hope to create an
interdisciplinary dialogue between the
fields of history finance and black
studies to complete my project this
summer with the support of our ITM I
went to the British National Archives
where explored several colonial office
records in particular I'll name to the
Colonial Office records
28:15 which contains several letters
about the illicit trade between Barbados
and the French and then : office records
137 / 2 that contains similar documents
with relation to Jamaica's illicit trade
with the Spanish collectively what these
documents show is that whether or not
sorry one second
primarily I won't argue from these
sources that
the support for piracy that went on
sometimes under the table by these
colonial governors shows that there was
a desperation for money in the colonies
and that it there was a definite means
to procure money through illicit trade
and what further research I'm going to
show that the currency from this trade
ended up in the hands of freedmen
enslaved people and was important to
their survival in these colonial spaces
thank you
[Applause]
hi my name is Gabriella Rivera I'm
Mapuche I'm a senior Erin a major I'm an
undergrad and I'm using images of street
art in Chile around Santiago in Tomoko
that I collected this past summer to
look at indigenous Mapuche urban
identities and resistance today against
state sanctioned violence is directed
against indigenous communities in Chile
and one question that I ask is to what
extent are these artworks examples of
manifestations of Mapuche resistance
because urban spaces are oftentimes not
seen as spaces inhabited by indigenous
peoples and therefore this becomes
indigenous space reclamation they can be
self erected memorials to victims of
police brutality like Matias car Alejo
who was murdered by a police officer
they can address hydro electric company
encroachment on Mapuche lands the
desecration of burial sites or current
mop which a political prisoners like
Francie scallion Canal who was arrested
under Chile's anti-terrorism law because
the state oftentimes perceives Mapuche
people as terrorists Minko now is
currently still in prison for her
resistance I also ask to what extent to
some of these murals in the heart of
Santiago point to an issue of
multiculturalism in the Chilean state or
the concept of promoting diversity
politics in a country often times while
still maintaining discriminatory
policies towards specific racial and
ethnic groups in Chile one of the
tenants that allows the multicultural
state to function is the concept of
Misti soccer which is typically defined
as the mixing of white Spanish or
colonizer blood with indigenous blood to
produce a quote-unquote new race or the
mestizo and I'm going to refer to it as
an ideology in an engagement with
Mapuche poet daniel Akaka three days
work she refers to misty sake has a
colonizer ideology which promotes the
assimilation of indigenous peoples into
white society and this further supports
the settler state by promoting a
diminishing of indigenous communities
through a pattern of self-identification
with whiteness and it creates a racial
hierarchy with the quote-unquote
actually indigenous peoples at the
bottom and then misty sauce and
whiteness on the top
many mestizos claim Native Heritage or
ancestry which relegate sour indigeneity
to the past as belonging to history
rather than as an active part of
ourselves today and promotes stereotypes
such as vanishing native
people and that indigenous peoples are
disappearing misty essential and society
are oftentimes the one enacting violence
against mop which at people and enacting
the violence on indigenous communities
that they perceive themselves to no
longer be a part of the street art in
Chile gets at complex layerings of
identities and of the presence of a
white settler state and ultimately I'm
going to draw parallels between
challange street art and settler state
violence's to transnational settler
state violence's protested by indigenous
produce murals in neighborhoods of color
that I've also collected in Baltimore in
Washington DC like murals containing
images of Freddie gray or Trayvon Martin
and I want to draw attention to a
variety of human rights violations and
in justices that settler states legally
and systemically perpetuate that we
continue to confront today Medici way OC
and mrs. Benson a mimosa thank you
[Applause]
hi I'm Sylvia Ryerson I'm a second-year
American Studies ph.d and the RIT M
summer research fellowship supported 10
weeks of field research for me in in
Eastern Kentucky on mass incarceration
in Central Appalachia since the 1990s
Central Appalachia has become one of the
most concentrated areas of rural prison
growth nationwide and many of these new
prisons are built on formerly
strip-mined mountaintop removal mined
land and so my initial research goal was
to document transfers of land ownership
from coal companies to prison sites
however within my weeks of first
arriving in Kentucky this summer one of
my research sites there was major news
that broke regarding the pending
construction of a new federal prison in
Letcher County Kentucky and this is the
prison proposal that was first proposed
to the county in 2008 and on June 20th
the Federal Bureau of Prisons withdrew
its record of decision to build USP
lecture which was projected to become
510 million dollar new high-security
prison this effectively defeated what
was slated to become the most expensive
federal prison ever built in US history
so due to this historic turn of events I
my research took a different direction
and I focused on the 15 years of local
and national organizing that made the
defeat of this prison possible and you
can see this is the proposed site and
this is a strip mine and I interviewed
many different people including some
local landowners and so here is one of
my interviews
[Music]
all of that code was brought up another
way busted might never be my
grandfather's cow pastures where he kept
his countenance similar you know there's
been officers that's what I thought was
gonna happen again
that's Mitch Whittaker who owned 15
acres of the 700 acre site located his
opposition to the prison within the
genealogy of organizing that his
grandfather and his father were part of
that oak was opposing radical strip
mining in the 1970s so that's what you
heard him talking about and he his
refusal to sell these 15 acres delayed
the whole project two years and was
pivotal in ultimately defeating this
proposal and he ended up joining a
historic lawsuit alongside 21
incarcerated people across the country
that sued the federal government against
the prison being constructed on the
grounds that it would cause unnecessary
harm so this research is central to a
journal article and currently
co-authoring observing what this our OD
Record of Decision withdraw reveals
about the current contradictions of the
u.s. carceral state and how a
multi-sided coalition of organizers
advocates and landowners strategically
exploited these contradictions and
created the space for radical and
groundbreaking opposition to the
carceral state to emerge in a place many
might not have expected or thought
possible
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Ahn cheol-soo
Roth and I'm a third year in American
Studies and EE GSS this summer I did a
combination of ethnographic and archival
work in order to consider the history of
indigenous anti-nuclear organizing in
the Pacific through an organization
known as a nuclear-free and a dependent
Pacific movement so the poster that is
on this poster right here as well as the
two photographs above are both
historical photos from NFIP mobilization
I also considered the material traces
left on Pacific Islanders subject to
nuclear detonations whose landscapes and
displacement point to the still present
nature of twentieth-century wars in the
Pacific the aerial photo of Majuro Atoll
in the Marshall Islands depicts the
ethnographic space in which I began to
ask the latter question more intently
and I took that photo from the plane
window for my research I visited the
National Archives of Australia in
Canberra and the National Archives of
Aotearoa or New Zealand and Wellington
as well as the archives at u H Manoa in
Honolulu Hawaii I also did preliminary
fieldwork in Majuro in the Marshall
Islands I have a few primary takeaways
from this experience first the politics
of the archive are deeply enmeshed with
empires entanglements within climate
change as many documents formerly
available in the Marshalls were lost due
to disaster events are moved to Imperial
archives due to sea level rise
second the Black Pacific is a generative
terrain of contestation within twentieth
century social movements in Oceania
especially in the ways that troubles
divides between blackness and
indigeneity in order to provide a
fulcrum for solidarity let's me I think
riffing on Monica's ideas of fulcrums
for solidarity third war is immediate
and the Marshalls it happened it is
happening it could happen at any given
moment
these coexisting temporalities remind me
that as I imagine Liberatore Pacific
Islander futures I must also account for
the colonial and south north settler
futures already set in motion by the
artifacts of war such as unexploded
ordinances human bones and various
stages of repatriation or loss and
American military ships rusting in the
fishing lagoon parts breaking off and
breaching sand where
children play finally Pacific Islander
women and queer people are and have been
at the helm of these trans indigenous
movements the sovereignty of their
bodies is a critical foundation to
further liberation while these are just
a handful of the revelations I had doing
research this summer they speak to a
much larger examination of nuclear
colonialism and indigenous resistance as
well as the transformations of race that
emerge from the migration catalyzed by
these unfolding processes
I think rhythm for funding this work it
has proven to be an extraordinarily
enriching summer thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Monique I'm a PhD
candidate in the Department of History
so two photo albums sit side by side in
the archives at UC Berkeley one of them
filled with mug shots replicated from a
long-lost set of original photographs in
the early 20th century under each mug
shot detailed descriptions of what the
men wore their hair styles and other
information that according to the eyes
of a Mexican anthropologist and his
research assistant told us just what
type of Mexican men these were another
filled with photographs just like this
one of men standing in a field with
either cows cars or horses in the
background and little to no information
about them beyond that they're from the
late 1920s and perhaps a name and a
hometown in another archive on the other
side of the bay area set a different set
of records Mexicans entering the US
through Angel Island whose names
birthdays kinship networks jobs enter
the historical record through emigration
workers and are found actually in
national archives of Chinese Exclusion
all of these archives are part of how
Mexican migrants from the middle class
escaping the Mexican Revolution to
migrant peasant workers laboring during
the Great Depression in agricultural
fields in the US enter the historical
record shepherded in by how a set of
experts or so-called experts understood
them anthropologists economists ans
workers the border patrol foot
photographers and bureaucrats of all
sorts on both sides of the us-mexico
border from 1910 to mid-century were
heavily concerned with Mexicans entering
the US but also of what type of Mexicans
were entering of how to racially
categorize them of how to understand and
read what they are
according to so-called experts and what
they saw in their faces clothing and
hairstyles this is a story made up of
different threads of how different
experts were establishing and
solidifying the racial category of
Mexican in the u.s. at the same time
that Mexican experts were solidifying a
national almost mythical mestizo Mexican
citizen after the Mexican Revolution
both were taking place in relation to
massive migrations of Mexicans within
Mexico
and in the US
and they specifically were concerned
with how one saw them what did their
clothes tell these experts about
economic station what did their
hairstyles tell them about their racial
locations about their gender
presentation and about who they were in
short what did one see when looking at a
Mexican these are questions that enter
the archive along with the photographs
and textual records that these experts
have used to try to figure out who these
Mexicans were how they fit into the
racial matrix of both the u.s. and
Mexico and how citizenship was being
fashioned on each side of the border but
also between them dependent on what one
saw when looking at a Mexican this is
the project that I've taken on for my
dissertation and that has slowly come
together in no small part thanks to the
generous funding and support of our ITM
over the last summer allowing me to
visit these archives sit with the
stories of these migrants and to begin
to figure out what it is that I see
thank you
[Applause]
all right I'm Adam waters I'm a second
year history PhD student and first well
it's just really wonderful to be able to
share my work alongside all of you so
thanks for that so on March 24th 1982 a
rally was held at Southside Presbyterian
Church in Tucson Arizona to declare
declare publicly that the church would
provide shelter to migrants fleeing
systemic violence in Central America
over the next several years hundreds of
churches synagogues mosques and other
religious communities joined the
sanctuary movement in supporting
migrants and protesting the Reagan
administration's policy toward Central
America likewise a constellation of
committees and organizations were birds
to Shepherd the movement at the local
regional and national levels and as is
common with political movements
especially those on the left numerous
and often serious disagreements emerged
over among other things the political
orientation of sanctuary in the role of
Central American migrants themselves in
the movement so the sanctuary movement
was the subject of intense media
coverage and a good deal of scholarly
research in its time but given where we
sat where we find ourselves today with
renewed conversations about migration
from Central America about migrant
detention and deportation regimes and
with the emergence of a new sanctuary
movement I think it's an opportune
moment to revisit the 1980s sanctuary
movement so this summer I spent a month
in Tucson conducting initial research on
the sanctuary movement and its
historical legacies my research was
primarily archival exploring several
sanctuary related collections at the
University of Arizona but I also had the
opportunity to get involved with local
organizations currently working in
humanitarian assistance and advocacy for
migrants many of which were created and
staffed and sustained by former
sanctuary workers my time in the
archives and my conversations with
migrant justice activists have sparked a
number of questions that I hope to
consider moving forward and so I'll
outline just a few conclusions for my
summer and avenues for further research
so first most works on sanctuary have
either focused on a local level and its
manifestations in a particular City in
Tucson in Los Angeles in San Francisco
or on the actions of its national
leadership but the documents that I
found made clear that the sanctuary
movement needs to be approached as a
multi scalar phenomenon I hope to
document the relationships and the
dynamics between actors at very
scales in order to present a more
comprehensive sense of how the movement
operated as a whole my research this
summer also made clear that the
sanctuary movement was a transnational
in international movement so
tucson-based activists were working
closely with church leaders in Central
America and in Mexico to develop what
they called an underground railroad that
brought migrants through Mexico across
the us-mexico border and into sanctuary
in the United States so far no one has
really been able to document how this
this trail actually functioned
particularly how it functions outside of
the borders of the United States and so
I imagine that my work in the future
will involve conducting fieldwork in
northern Guatemala and in Mexico and
finally I think there's a lot more to be
done to think about how the sanctuary
movement fits into larger histories of
immigration policy migrant justice
activism left politics and progressive
religion in the late 20th century in the
United States and in the American Latin
America I'm particularly interested in
situating sanctuary as part of an
emerging migrant justice praxis one that
stretches from the 1970s through to the
present thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you